>> Greg: SO, REPEATING THE
SAME THING OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN WILL NEVER MAKE IT
TRUE.
HE CONTINUES TO FIND THAT OUT
THE HARD WAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN CLEARER IN HIS ARTICULATION
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION'S
POSITION, NOR COULD I HAVE BEEN
CLEARER AND CONTINUE TO BE SO,
WHICH IS THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTERS AND ENFORCES THE
LAWS OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> Greg: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING THAT
WHILE EXCLUSIVE NEW VIDEO SHOWS
MIGRANTS GOING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
THEY STOPPED TEN SEX OFFENDERS
OVER A ONE-WEEK PERIOD.
I'M GOING TO GO OVER THE ICKY
STUFF.
3166% INCREASE IN ARRESTS OF
CONVICTED SEX OFFENDERS.
THIS INCLUDED PEOPLE CHARGED
WITH ACTS WITH CHILDREN, ASSAULT
OF CHILDREN COME PERSONS UNDER
13.
STATUTORY RAPE.
THESE ARE NOT THE BEST PEOPLE IS
WHAT WE ARE GETTING AT.
>> Geraldo: I THINK YOU ARE
WRONG ABOUT THAT.
IT'S OF COURSE INTERESTING TO
EMPHASIZE THESE ABHORRENT PEOPLE
WHO COME OVER.
THEY SHOULD BE ARRESTED, THEIR
HANDS SMASHED.
THEY SHOULD BE SENT AWAY
FOREVER.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THESE PEOPLE RUNNING THROUGH
THE BUSHES THAT WE ALL HAVE BEEN
SEEN THANKS TO THE DRONE FOOTAGE
THAT WE ARE GETTING FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
WHERE ARE THEY GOING?
THE VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
NEVER SEE THEM.
WHY DID THE NEVER SEE THEM?
BECAUSE THEY ARE ABSORBED INTO
OUR ECONOMY.
THEY ARE BABYSITTING.
THEY ARE MOWING THE LAWN.
THEY ARE WASHING THE DISHES IN
THE RESTAURANT.
THEY ARE WORKING IN THE POULTRY
PROCESSING PLANT AND THE MEAT
PACKING PLANT.
THEY ARE GOING ACROSS THE BORDER
BECAUSE AMERICAN EMPLOYERS ARE
SAYING COME ON, WE'VE GOT JOBS
FOR YOU.
YOU SEE ALL THESE HELP-WANTED
SIGNS?
THESE PEOPLE ARE HEADING
SOMEPLACE WHERE THEY ARE GOING
TO BE ABSORBED INTO THE FABRIC
OF THE COUNTRY.
OVER 11 MILLION ARE HERE AND I
THINK THAT NUMBER IS WAY LOW.
I THINK THERE'S MORE THAN THAT.
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT AS
LONG AS WE ARE PULLING, GIVING
THEM THE MAGNET, COME ON, WE
WILL GIVE YOU A JOB, THEY ARE
WANT TO COME.
>> Greg: BUT THERE IS
SOMETHING CALLED A PROCESS.
IF YOU WANT A PROCESS, IT
DOESN'T MAKE YOU
ANTI-IMMIGRATION.
WE DO HAVE JOBS.
BUT IF THEY TAKE THEIR JOBS, THE
WAGES WILL BE LOWER AND THE
LIBERALS CAN'T ASK FOR A HIGHER
WAGE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS, JESSE?
>> Jesse: IT DRIVES WAGES DOWN
FOR HARDWORKING AMERICANS.
I AGREE.
THAT IS NOT ORDERLY.
HE REMINDS ME OF THE REPORTER
THAT STOOD IN FRONT OF THE
BURNING BUILDING AND SO THIS WAS
A PEACEFUL PROTEST.
WHAT ELSE IS HE GOING TO TELL
US?
THERE ARE PEOPLE RUNNING ACROSS.
NO, NO, NO.
THEY ARE GETTING READY FOR THE
GAMES.
HE THINKS WE ARE STUPID, RIGHT?
WE ARE STUPID.
IF YOU SAW A BAR WITH 100 PEOPLE
IN IT, WOULD YOU SIT AT THE BAR
IS CLOSED?
NO, THE BAR IS NOT CLOSE.
THE BOUNCER BOOED OUT TO
COPEOPLE BUT EVERY TWO PEOPLE HE
BOUNCES OUT, FOUR PEOPLE COME
BACK IN.
THAT'S NOT CLOSE.
THAT'S HAPPY HOUR.
AND THEN THEY ARE SAYING WE
WON'T EVEN DEPORT YOU ALSO
UNLESS YOU ARE CONVICTED OF AN
AGGRAVATED FELONY.
SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY PUNCH ME IN
THE FACE AND JOE BIDEN WON'T
DEPORT YOU.
YOU COULD GET DRUNK AND DRIVE
YOUR CAR INTO GREG GUTFELD'S
HOUSE.
>> Greg: NO!
>> Jesse: AND THEY WON'T
REPORT YOU.
YOU CAN GRAFFITI DANA'S BEACH
HOUSE AND THEY WON'T DEPORT YOU.
THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS
THAT YOU CAN DO.
BANK FRAUD.
YOU CAN STEAL GERALDO'S
CREDIT CARD, TAKE OUT LOANS, AND
THEY WON'T DEPORT YOU.
AND YOU CAN PROBABLY TAKE OUT A
LOT OF LOANS ON GERALDO'S LINE
OF CREDIT.
TRUMP IS RIGHT.
REMEMBER HE SAID THAT THEY WERE
LETTING IN RAPISTS?
THERE ARE NOW TEN OF THEM.
>> Greg: I ACTUALLY LOOKED
INTO THE LAWS AND IF YOU PUNCH
JESSE IN THE FACE, YOU GET
INSTANT CITIZENSHIP.
>> Jesse: THAT'S ON THE BOOKS?
>> Greg: THAT'S ACTUALLY ON
THE BOOKS.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE INCITING
PEOPLE NOW.
>> Greg: I AM.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OR RAMIFICATIONS
FOR THIS.
I DOUBT THAT WE ARE CLOSELY
MONITORING THE COVID SYMPTOMS
AND ALL OF THE PEOPLE COMING IN.
>> Dr. Nicole: IT'S A LOT MORE
THAN THAT, GREG.
I DID A LOT OF MY TRAINING IN
ARIZONA AND I WORKED IN THE
COUNTY HOSPITAL.
I HELPED PREPARE A LOT OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IT'S KIND OF GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
WE DON'T WANT TO BRING PEOPLE IN
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES WHO MAY BE
BRINGING IN DIFFERENT VARIANCE.
CARDIAC FAILURE.
THEY GET VERY SICK.
THEY COME AND THEY NEED
HEALTH CARE.
AND YOU KNOW, THERE IS A
PARALLEL INCREASE IN CRIME WHEN
IT COMES TO ACTIVITY.
BUT AS GERALDO DID POINT OUT, A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SEEKING
REFUGE.
BUT THERE IS A PROCESS TO THAT
AND AS WE ARE SEEING COME OF
WHOLE ABOLISH ICE MOVEMENT NEEDS
TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
THERE.
IT DIDN'T GO OVER WELL.
WE NEED TO ENFORCE THIS PROCESS
TO GET PEOPLE OVER SAFELY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW DANA, IT
SEEMS TO BE THE STRATEGY HERE.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE TO LET THE
AMERICAN ATTENTION SPAN SIMPLY
FATIGUE.
THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT OVER
TIME, WE WILL JUST LOSE INTEREST
IN THIS STORY.
SUMMER COMES, AND THIS WILL JUST
KIND OF LIKE CONTINUE ON.
IT REMINDS ME OF PORTLAND, HOW
PORTLAND COME EVERY NIGHT IT'S
THE SAME PROBLEM.
STILL THERE.
>> Dana: I KNOW, DAN SPRINGER
DID A REPORT FOR US THE OTHER
DAY.
EVEN THOUGH WAS BREAKING NEWS, I
FELT LIKE I HAD SEEN IT 100
TIMES BEFORE BECAUSE IT'S GOING
ON EVERY NIGHT.
I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK I'VE EVER
SEEN A LESS EFFECTIVE
COMMUNICATOR THAN SECRETARY
MAYORKAS.
I'M NOT EVEN SURE THERE'S A REAL
PERSON IN THERE.
THE WAY HE TALKS ABOUT IT, IT
SOUNDS ROBOTIC.
THERE ARE TWO POSSIBLE THINGS
ARE GOING TO HAPPEN ON A POLICY
FRONT TO KEEP IN MIND.
ON THE COVID ISSUE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT BASICALLY SAID YOU
ARE COMING FROM A COUNTRY THAT
HAS HIGH COVID CASES, THEN YOU
CAN BE BASICALLY DEPORTED RIGHT
AWAY AND TURNED AWAY.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO COME IN.
APPARENTLY THAT COULD GO AWAY
SOON.
SO THERE GOES ANOTHER TOOL.
AND THE OTHER THING IS THIS JUST
BROKE AND I'M WORKING ON GETTING
THE DETAILS.
WHEN YOU APPLY FOR A GREEN CARD,
YOUR WIFE DID, MY HUSBAND DID.
YOU HAD TO FILL OUT ALL THIS
PAPERWORK AND SAY ALL THESE
THINGS.
ON THE FORM IS A THING ABOUT ANY
PAST PUNISHMENTS OR JAIL TERMS
OR CONVICTIONS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
THAT HELPS THE PROCESS BE DONE
PROPERLY.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO TAKE THAT OUT.
>> THAT'S CRAZY.
>> Dana: THAT WHEN IT BE
SOMETHING YOU HAD TO ADMIT TO
WHEN YOU ARE APPLYING FOR